[Music]
all right when do you not look like this
I mean I know you're not around in the
gallon all this really yes
give me a time that you've ever looked
bad this morning really yeah you don't
like get out of bed looking like this we
all think you do
No are you insane you're an insane
person no I'm not I really I'm very I'm
not very nice I'm in like a terrible
sweat pan with a terrible t-shirt it's
not and like eye boogers it's not a good
it's not a good look it makes us all
feel a lot better right now did you all
hear that she actually has not an eye
boogers all right how many addresses did
you go through before you decided this
it's the first one as everyone always
does so when you did you see like a
couple of racks and then you said okay
that one I think is gonna be my favorite
well no I I literally said to my stylist
Robin Muriel I said you know what do you
guys love they go this when I go okay
let's wear it and we tried it on to go
yeah duh well I mean when you have your
figure it's like hey all I'm going on
yeah that's not true either but this one
just happened to be that like perfect
fit their congratulations on everything
thank you so much how does it feel to be
here at the ILI's walking a me my first
time with a me my very first time at the
Emmys it's really wonderful
in television as everybody knows it's
just blossoming for everybody
specifically for women it's really
exciting and I'm here with the well I'm
I'm here presenting but I'm also I had
this amazing show that my products my
fantasy part and I produced and helped
develop and it's really exciting is
Jessica to be here to fewer debates baby
oh he's um he's in Brazil actually he's
headlining Rock in Rio did he get a
little bit jealous of the fact that
because you did that absolutely perfect
dance move the other day on Ellen I mean
come on better moves than anybody in the
world like I can't compete with that
this is true but you actually said he
was the one who you had to thank for
that right the ability to do that all
the time is a poem like are you ready
here I come I'm you're gonna do it he's
like oh god here we go again
like just suck it up and do it this is
you're now married to me which means you
have to do what I say this is good so
here we come he's he's such a good
dancer like I can't I can't even come
close to his skills and that's just the
reality I just maybe he was jealous
because you practiced with him and then
the guy that you did it with on Ellen
like got all the acclaim yeah not a
jealous person he's like go have fun
enjoy do something amazing have fun
guests come home and then we'll do it
again but yeah go home at which
we'll have a great time as Amy it's an
item glad you're here you look gorgeous
[Music]